well this lady said she banged a bunch
of poltergeists that's close
it's pretty cool that's like a sex
island on a different astral plane yeah
it's the collection I want to marry and
start a family with a ghost mushy
British yeah of course is the ghost
wearing a lot of ruffles and very dusty
balls on a shoe was the ghost possibly
wearing a powdered wig yeah is he having
a position like Cantor or something like
that this is a real presence in your in
your life your spiritual guidance
constantly you're used to this sort of
thing you open up channels to the other
side again oh yes none of these ghosts
are gay it's why he's letting walk
around with that hair you open channels
to the other side yes I guess you could
call it that just have a baby with a
ghost which is she has she just did you
see it I'd want to hang it's a ghost
pregnancy belly so yeah yeah at this
person this this presence can you tell
us anything about
him/her it I first as him cuz that's
easier yeah very ancient very wise very
kind husbands are you like older man is
it I can appreciate that and oldest my
boyfriend is a Revolutionary War soldier
any of cool-cool my girlfriend is clear
path I feel like
Anna Nicole Smith finish up oh oh yeah
she called me off she Dave oh she's a
bad bad how this bedroom real bad easy
buddy
you go for my boyfriend's a 15th century
streets Oh been working out all died
figured I'll come back and put a baby in
yeah
Ione hours work you want me to give you
a good ghost shaggy no oh yeah you ready
for this uncircumcised goats dick you
ready to put my Specter and you spent
there hello how are you
when you and he talked what'd you talk
about
it's really difficult to explain in
terms of normal like earthbound
relationships what it's a bit deeper
than that we don't have oh you asshole
of course we're at yoga pants' saying
you're deeper than all of us I want to
give an answer like what's he saying he
goes we just talked about his ghost day
and he's in a ghost fantasy football
league takes up a lot of time he makes
me watch the Jets but I want to go I
want to go to sex honor if I could out
car do sex art and this is ridiculous
not considered mental illness anymore
like somebody can say they're gonna
whatever mr. merry ghost and we're like
oh no we need except that I convinced
Christina's go through the first
relationship no one else can see me died
40 years ago
my drag race often his bluff I didn't
have to do a whole I have to do a
transfer you have to do a I'm gonna
cross over just for you I'm gonna give
up heaven for you because he goes oh my
god you're like and then Dave's like
hate you to go yeah what's up I'm doing
the thing that Christine tell us I'm
still a ghost yeah I need to give me one
second hold on transforming a day sorry
all back this met the world I need you
to help me escape on that your love can
make me really get hang on one second
hold on yeah no yeah no buzzing buzzing
I got ya
this guy he goes is there extra cheese
the hose is there extra cheese because I
ordered it well look did you fall with
this thing yeah the high you just take
that just take it typically the
haul-back
the host is this guy's so great the look
on his face right now yeah doesn't say
he's buying it look like yet for so
these guys are coming by you saying any
your sandwich is about emotion and
feeling in connection but you know that
you may be you may be feeling and
connecting a bit more than you know more
than that because you feel that you're
going to connect to such a degree am i
right that you will have a spiritual or
physical baby baby type say what what
spiritual or physical more than that I
would hope physical I don't
I hope this lunatic walks around with a
piece of her own and wrapped in
toilet paper for a week you won't see my
spirit baby just Oh God Oh amethyst that
is that is gone you gotta throw that out
and with this impute but real quick okay
what are you eating
that's what Ceylon great a lot of bugs
how many days has been out of you have
you it's hardened you took a googly eyes
on a piece of now what he means
baby I have we go smoothly as half ghost
that's a baby your ghost boyfriend she
goes well ghost husband
he made me an honest woman we marry we
would've had a baby out of wedlock we
wouldn't no no no you know what it's
like working at the ghost Center yeah I
know I answer calls at the coast Center
next to you for five years all right
guys I'm gonna cross over other words
talking boyfriend now you guys wouldn't
get it you would understand it's too
deep for the human realm by rank he
gives some privacy please man have sex
with a ghost boyfriend man bout to go
get drilled out by a guy that died when
they thought the earth was flat
is it Florence from Florence in the
Machine touch everyone next to you and
say about the dump some ghost dick in
this relax your eyes and look between
realms close your eyes and look again
everything's glitter Florence it's
actually a real pregnancy but you have a
phantom inside you rather than a human
baby so that's easy and Christine so if
you ever get the itch we could
definitely have a fancy baby you're not
a ghost Oh am i listen here's well do
I'll go out one day I might be going for
a while but I'm gonna come back I'm
gonna go to the ghost sperm bank oh I'm
gonna get you some ghosts you make sure
you get a good we'll put it in you and
then you'll have a phantom baby and uh I
don't know you call it a day nine months
do you want to make it legit or you want
to start this thing up the next day
supreme
I'm sorry there were complications
Christine this phantom umbilical cord
was around his phantom Anakin he walked
into his brain was being he's alive
don't worry he's very much alive dead
challenged baby yeah I'm just I'm sorry
I'm having some folks in IV especially
it's ghost fantasy getting offended at
comics that do ghosts retard baby okay
all right you know what is that funny I
have a seventh month old that is
mentally disabled and a ghost just sits
there in the park and has her tit
hanging out with nothing happening and
she goes you know something some on your
mind you want to say something say
something this is beautiful and natural
in another realm
this is looked at its beauty okay all
right asshole so I grow it's a
fun time baby so it comes on down and
doesn't care it's leap properly suppose
an empty stroller around you can
see we get it we can have a phantom baby
baby shower those oh I'll come over for
that a phantom gender reveal party
before I buy a president for a phantom
baby that I'm coming over with baby
powder and I'm throwing it around the
bro just show me show me footsteps
or something soda I just drop 90 bucks
on the log-dog you know Christine gets
can you please just so you see the fans
of a tree oh no I want to prove this
thing's real i watch that Kevin Bacon
movie I know how to get them I'm gonna
holla man this a lot of people
wouldn't understand their miscarriages
just you queefing out phantom children
yeah oh you left where did you leave
your baby
at the hospital didn't think oh my god
those babies didn't survive it's
actually a tragic thing
yeah but she's describing like that was
gonna happen not go full term make the
mistake of thinking because because of
the accent I think English people are
much more intelligent you hear wing
enough it really turns out they are
just gravel chomping no fluoride
teeth yeah put some hard these limey
just out there spreading lives
extreme version of a girlfriend and
Niagara Falls yeah I even know he's a
ghost you would know yeah do you know
ghosts oh you're gonna stop going
looking questions you go to the ghost
high school it's my boyfriend he's the
quarterback of the ghost football team I
used to just state all vampires and
werewolves and I got like I hate it they
got so many issues my daughters are like
they change on you all the time I think
loners this guys are all family dudes
it's like oh my entire covens no thanks
I need a ghost who just I like a guy
that's independent comes and goes when
he was between this Romeo there is such
a bad boy he's got a ghost leather
jacket Oh sometimes he goes back to
another world and he won't answer his
phone for a couple days I wasn't jealous
and hot love it and I know he's got an
axe on that plane I know that astral
plane and he's just like I know he
Caesar he doesn't tell me when he sees
they get coffee because they're like
legit friends I'm doing my best not to
get jealous cuz they also I just said
before also he's got a phantom baby with
an actual phantom she goes and so
different spirit and his fans his
phantom baby from his first marriage
means a lot to him and I love that about
him it's why I want to have a half human
half anime be with him now so how you
guys gonna make this family like come
together guys do you understand anything
about quantum physics oh my god you have
to flip the physical and the spiritual
world for in order to shake up it's like
when you mix something it's like why am
I giving this show you guys don't get it
good
the ghosts or presents whatever you like
to call it
his name's Philip means marker Philip
he's fire they're all feel if you're
familiar with him you mess in the
Australian bush and you had to leave
Australia yeah and you were feeling very
sad about leaving its presence behind I
was chased out by a necromancer dude
this is so funny go back her her
her ghost husband lives in Australia
it's just a guy sitting behind a bush
with her he goes yeah all thank
you believes it she really thinks I'm
alive I'm a real ghost
that sucks dev you have a ghost husband
and he's not present very much
oh very busy babe ah come on yeah about
four houses I thought a mental asylum
I've got a little boy I got to scare the
out of be CEO yeah baby I'm
back to the guilt rying to keep a little
bugger in line from over in Liverpool
sometimes when people stay at a hotel I
don't like to up their experience a
little bit I gotta go turn on some
sprinkler systems in a hotel later oh I
gotta move a cart of food up and down a
hallway for a little bit oh I love to
but I'm blowing out candles and castles
all night movie just oh babe I totally
forgot I have to walk through the back
of a picture to notice me I got a photo
shoot to say I'm sorry I have to be the
third thing under a under a sheet that's
hanging up the first two things are
other things but was that further on
there he's gonna be me there's so much
wood that needs creaking I wish I could
all the wood would creak itself but I
can I'm the one dragging these chains
around these castle steps there for one
nothing you can't take care of one
phantom baby warmer
boyfriend in the behind the play because
he was sitting next to me he was running
down the tend to be quite static and
sorry for I've had to leave it behind
and then whilst was on the plane just
suddenly realized they surprised me and
yeah come with me I'm try I'm trying to
understand this is this similar to being
possessed almost much stupider than that
a real question for you what did you
fall fall and hit your head cuz you had
a loony one who did it to you
girl who did the damage who did you see
use your SkyMiles
just wondering because someone bought a
ticket I'm sure of it those flights that
I staying do you mind having a girl
argue with you you're sitting on her
fiance do you mind switching with me on
say that empty chair over there why do i
why do i yes sir it's a we don't be
together much and i just want to i get
nervous on flights and he calms me down
because that's a middle seat i can't do
a middle seat yeah that's sir please
i can you not think about yourself right
now but it i needed i requested a window
seat because it's a flight from
australia don't you k you're a
dimension esta Niko's
okay you know what get my stuff macho I
think my left up
can you move move your feet you're a
fancy mist what is this you're dimension
is oh yeah the William Shatner some
thing there's a ghost who's in love with
the woman it's John Lithgow in the movie
yeah that's the one I know that 12 hour
movie is terrifying there's
something on the wing some thing oh the
wing like is this here right now
is he look at me
Did you touch me right now he's been
having sex with his testes in your water
it's similar to a normal life band
relationship just except it's not what
there's no one can meet or see or greet
or see that the love that you are
experiencing so I'm trying to to imagine
what this is like and I'm thinking maybe
this is like having a really nice dream
yeah that you can go back into an optin
to whenever you want she's gotten so
good now like giggling and just knowing
that people think she's bonkers so she's
one cuz she's goes you just accepted
this was people gonna do you're gonna
make up your wacky story yeah and you
know I nearly hey I'll tell people that
sure gave me the balls to go on TV and
be like yeah I'm dating a guest hi Dan
Soder I'm in love with the ghost when we
come back I'm gonna tell everybody how
to love cave here she is yeah yeah she's
a firecracker like side mouth I start
randomly getting a girl or ghost huge Oh
baby girls getting handsy
Oh baby I knew that it was just weird
for you guys yes
hello run a bit bring up a shot
that one's tickling my belly my belly
run a bit I'm sorry I'm fascinated by
this woman because she's so full of
she has to be right
ghost are you being touched or you've
been held are you being kissed on you
being owes it just come all of it and
that's a normal relationship so you get
excited saying that but it's not a
normal relationship
I lose it I'm lady Dan any follow-up
questions guys it's not a normal
relationship you can't wear those moron
pants and come here and tell me this
nonsense I mean are you warming up what
are you doing yeah we did you just say
that actually on the flight back from
Australia you did yeah go into the loo
and you're a member of the mile-high
club with a ghost that is no even know
what a mile is yeah that's a it's a
kilometer yet done yeah we're in the
kilometer high club I mean what an
asshole
she's just lied we did what people do
this piss and alone she came out
and she's like I'm feeding really Randi
I'm sorry
she messed her own hair Caeser coming
out the door he's like yeah she's in
their own the guy on that flight had to
be like what the she scooped uncie
scooped unstirred yogurt into the front
of a condom she was sorry every bar a
mystical so ray whoever do the sound of
physical evidence what you gonna do
about that she's just saying that
like she should one of these sex
island guys hell yeah because here
like oh yeah is your girl's boyfriend
like a fall the time she don't even know
but we just had annoying some nonsan was
out with the entire dead I hope you like
sloppy 31st
I just got gangbanged on the dead
marshal football do we are Marshall oh
my god that's so tragic is it cuz I had
sex with patty Holly the Big Bopper big
Ritchie Valens my father will kill me
for the Mexican boy my father would
not like me to be with the Mexican boy
but Big Bopper Holly human sir this is
ridiculous
healthy now
fine we have kale smoothies every
morning Curtis this is so dumb how do we
just get to this she is unlike me
husband because he eats a lot of
pineapple if you know what I mean his
ghost tastes sweet all right let's
just get a little lunch you have these
feelings because you imagine them not
because it's actually a a ghost yeah I
mean for me I know that it's real and
but it's my it's my relationship it's
personal I don't mind so much of people
just believe you for their religious
personal accepts we're getting getting
railed in the bathroom by
nothing yeah but yeah man buy a stiff
breeze a stiff breeze did you the
plunger just get what you mean Philip
oh no Philip used to plunger on me he's
a crazy one Philips a bit of a shag
master
[Music]
you